Depression isn't always obvious or easy to spy
Social media and Hollywood often depicted in its most serious stage with raging mood swings and intense hopelessness
But depression can range from mild to severe and it has a habit of sneaking up on us in our everyday routines
This is why many people often struggle with it silently when the symptoms aren't always so clear-cut
Here are six signs. You may have depression and not even know it
One you keep yourself crazy busy the older we get the more natural
It is for our schedules to fill up with duties to fulfill and chores to complete
But when you have depression, you are more likely to drown yourself in work a study published in the journal PLoS
ONE shows that there is a correlation between workaholism and symptoms of psychiatric disorders such as anxiety and depression
medical doctor Sumi Lee Samuel at Timberline Knowles a residential treatment center in Illinois
States that keeping busy might be a way for people to ignore or avoid painful issues that may be contributing to or triggering their depression
Your boss might be pleased with your work ethic in your kitchen counter might be spic-and-span
But we encourage you to pay close attention to your heart if it feels heavier than usual
Please don't hesitate to reach out to others for help
- you're hurting everywhere
According to the Mayo Clinic pain and depression are closely linked and related to one another in
Many people depression can cause unexplained physical symptoms such as back pain and headaches
The reverse also holds true in which chronic pain can lead to depression along with various other problems such as difficulty sleeping
stress and low self-esteem due to legal work or financial issues
We recommend that you talk to your doctor and seek the right treatment that works for you whether it means taking medication using talk therapy
attending pain rehabilitation programs or practicing stress reduction techniques
3 you've either gained or lost a lot of weight
Depression can make you swing in extremes in one direction or the other if you notice a difference in your appetite
Whether it's gone down or went up it might have to do with the emotional pain you're feeling
Some people don't feel like eating when they're down and dejected
whereas others who usually eat healthy might have a craving for junk food and take-out as they try to fill up the void in their
lives
We recommend that you try healthy comfort food recipes to keep yourself nourished with the essential nutrients your body needs during stressful times
For you can't seem to make up your mind
clinical psychologist
Elizabeth Lombardo author of better than perfect states that psychologically when we're depressed
We lose gray matter that affects the parts of our brains that facilitates our motivation and decision-making
Even the smallest decisions we make on a daily basis like choosing coffee or tea can be a struggle when we lack focus and determination
The next time you have a hard time making a choice
Try to go with your first
Instinct and know that you still have the power to turn things around if you feel like you made the wrong decision
5 you're glued to your phone or computer
Simon rego associate professor of clinical psychiatry and director of psychology training at Montefiore Medical
Center states that people with depression often go on a quest for a short-term boost as a common coping mechanism
Whether that means gambling facebooking or shopping
Virtual social interactions are sought more than real ones from those who feel depressed
In fact, although Internet addiction and depression are separate diagnoses. They often overlap with one another
The next time you're glued to your Instagram or splurged on many pairs of designer shoes
We encourage you to reflect and ask yourself if you're okay
6 the slightest things set you off
irritability is a common sign that most people overlook if
You find that you're more impatient when you're waiting in line at the grocery store or get agitated
When the light turns red at stoplights, there may be more going on underneath your size and frustration
Tyrannous is also an indicator that you may have depression
Small issues can feel enormous when you're depressed. You may notice that you're crying more easily than usual or have trouble controlling your tears
Depression has an odd way of overwhelming us and instead of repressing our feelings
We should let them out naturally and learn not to be so hard on ourselves
Do you think you might be struggling with depression?
We want you to know that you're not alone and we're here to help you. Please share your thoughts with us below
Also, don't forget to subscribe for more content from Psych to go and check out our patreon. Thanks for watching